y me llegó la regla a los 11 con dolores
de barriga terribles a los 16 mm o me
llevó a ver a un ginecólogo señorita es
normal tener dolores durante su regla me
dijo le vamos a dar un analgésico una
publicidad directa de la asociación info
endometriosis la actriz es su
cofundadora el cirujano me dijo usted
tiene endometriosis y vos
una que le respondí una endometriosis y
vos
no es su historia julie interpretó una
paciente que tiene la enfermedad en
francia una de cada diez mujeres padece
este mal en qué células del endometrio
se instalan en distintas partes del
organismo aparato reproductor pero
incluso los pulmones y el corazón
cada vez que viene la regla la persona
se llena de dolores
cecil tony dirige info endometriosis y
padece la enfermedad en esa época yo
pasaba por histérica no podía decir que
me dolía como no sabía lo que tenía no
podía ni siquiera hablar estaba sola con
mis dolores y mis problemas en el 2015
gracias a info endometriosis la
enfermedad se hizo conocida la palabra
de las mujeres se liberó y con ello el
tabú de la regla gracias al impulso
sobre todo de la nueva generación la
juventud de hoy habla no tiene tabúes es
más despierta y comprometida y sobre
todo más feminista muchos coinciden en
que durante décadas la enfermedad fue
dejada de lado a propósito era mal
administrado por los hombres porque
estaba ligada a la regla y porque se
piensa que las mujeres siempre tienen
derecho a sufrir o callarse si los
hombres la hubieran tenido creo que la
investigación habría avanzado mucho más
habría más recursos y tendríamos más
respuestas a esta enfermedad
es decir creo también un podcast mi
endometriosis y en este estudio
entrevistó a nueve mujeres vamos a
comenzar gracias por darme la palabra me
siento honrado espero estar a la altura
hoy en este último episodio benjamãn su
marido toma las riendas y la
entrevistadora se convierte en
entrevistada a veces las mujeres saben
más sobre endometriosis que sus médicos
no me da vergüenza decirlo porque es
verdad
hace tres años un solo día estaba
dedicado a esta enfermedad de la carrera
de medicina hoy la ciencia trata de
recuperar el tiempo perdido pero siguen
siendo necesarios varios años para ser
diagnosticadas espere 14 años para tener
diagnóstico
para que mi dolor fuera reconocido para
hacer avanzar las cosas del instituto de
salud e investigación francés firmó un
acuerdo con un fondo metros ys es la
primera vez que el instituto trabaja
mano a mano con una asociación
con andrés es parte del reducido equipo
de investigadores
su objetivo descubrir genes portadores
de la enfermedad en una misma familia
contacte a muchas familias que tenían
varios casos de la enfermedad
hablé con cada miembro enfermo y con los
sanos también y todos quedaron incluidos
en el proyecto de investigación la
persona recibe entonces este sobre con
un kit de recogida de saliva no hay que
escupir en el embudo
uno se lo pone aquí
se estima una irritabilidad de más del
50% el lado genético si bien no es la
causa de la enfermedad es un
contribuyente muy importante de la
endometriosis
cuando el tubo regresó al hospital el
equipo debe extraer el adn hoy los
medios adjudicados son muy limitados
diez mil euros
la operación cuesta 500 por paciente
solo 20 entonces pueden beneficiarse de
este estudio es muy invalidante pero no
es mortal está el hecho también de que
sea una enfermedad femenina y por eso la
tomaron menos en serio si la única
enfermedad humana fuera la endometriosis
y no el cáncer o el alzhéimer
encontraríamos los medios y el problema
sería resuelto en un par de años no se
muere de endometriosis pero tampoco las
personas se curan y sobre todo la
enfermedad es la primera causa de
infertilidad en las mujeres francesas
hice tres inseminaciones invito y cada
vez es más complicado doloroso no se
crea esperanzas y luego no funcionan
y la colecta de fondos no se detiene las
fronteras de francia
bienvenidos al parlamento europeo desde
el 2019 cris hula es eurodiputada pero
ante todo es ginecóloga especializada en
la endometriosis una feo ni voz del
unión europea a nivel de la unión
europea hicimos un compromiso fuerte
para combatir el cáncer con baja de
cáncer
porque no en algunos años tenía también
un plan para la endometriosis
el desafío es grande pero ella siente
que ha llegado el momento en el
parlamento europeo un 40 por ciento de
los escaños pertenecen a mujeres en este
tema los 26 no avanzan parejo pese a sus
limitaciones francia es de los buenos
alumnos francia ha tenido mucho éxito y
queremos mostrar el ejemplo pero aquí
hay que entender también la realidad de
cada país
es simbólico quienes fuimos a quién soy
yo para criticarse grisú la es hija de
europa nació en grecia gratis estudio en
italia y ha pasado una parte de su vida
la variz para especializarse en este mal
saber se atiende gratis en parís ya
operado a muchas mujeres que hoy son
madres su oficina de parlamentaria está
llena de eslóganes feministas y afiches
de simone veil como si se tratara de una
carrera de relevos entre el derecho al
aborto hace 46 años y el fin del dolor